As an Australian Canadian
the Fahrenheit temperature scale has
always seemed a bit arbitrary to me.
I mean why does water
freezes at 32 degrees?
Why that integer and what exactly does 0 represent?
According to many sources
the Fahrenheit scale was
defined by setting 0 degrees
equal to the temperature of
the ice salt and water mixture
And a hundred degrees being
roughly equal to human body temperature.
But that isn't true.
The real story is much more
interesting and scientific.
August 14th, 1701 was
almost certainly the worst day
in the life of 15 year-old
Daniel Gabriel Fahrenheit.
On that day, both of his parents
died suddenly from mushroom poisoning.
And he was sent from Poland
where he lived
to Amsterdam to become
an apprentice bookkeeper.
But Fahrenheit couldn't
stand his apprenticeship and
ran away so many times that his employer
put out a warrant for his arrest.
Traveling from city to city around Europe,
he became fascinated with
scientific instruments
and in particular, thermometers.
In 1708, possibly seeking help
with the warrant,
Fahrenheit met with
the mayor of Copenhagen,
who happened to be
the famous astronomer Ole Rømer.
Rømer is known for observing
the eclipses of Jupiter's moons
and realizing that variations
in the timing of those eclipses
was caused by the time
it took light to reach Earth.
In other words, he found a way
to accurately measure
the finite speed of light.
But, more pertinent to this story,
in 1702, Rømer was housebound
after breaking his leg.
And to pass the time, he devised a
brand-new temperature scale
with the freezing point of water
at 7.5 degrees
and body temperature at 22.5 degrees.
Now, this might seem odd
until you consider that Rømer wanted
the boiling point of
water to be 60 degrees.
As an astronomer, he had
experience dividing things by 60.
So if you take this scale,
divide it in half, in half again
and in half once more,
you find the freezing point of water
one eighth up the scale,
and human body temperature
three eighth up the scale.
So at their meeting in 1708
Fahrenheit learned of Rømer's temperature
scale and adopted it as his own,
adjusting it slightly because he found it
"inconvenient and inelegant on
account of fractional numbers".
So he scaled them up to 8 and 24.
And this is the original Fahrenheit scale.
He produced thermometers
for some time using this scale.
But then at some later point,
Fahrenheit multiplied all numbers
on the scale by 4
setting freezing point to the now-familiar
32 and body temperature to 96.
It's unclear exactly why he did this.
He may just have wanted
finer precision in his measurements.
But I think there was a better reason.
You see, Fahrenheit was an
excellent instrument maker.
His thermometers agreed
with each other precisely
at a time when that was unheard of.
He pioneered the use of mercury
as a measuring liquid,
which has the benefit of a much higher
boiling point than the alcohol
used in most other
thermometers at the time.
And for these accomplishments
he was inducted into
the British Royal Society.
And we know that he read
the works of Newton, Boyle, and Hook,
in which he would have come across the idea
that one degree increase in
temperature could correspond to
a specific fractional increase in
the volume of the measuring liquid.
And today, a one degree Fahrenheit
increase in temperature
increases the volume of
mercury by exactly one part in 10,000.
Is this just a coincidence?
Well, we'll probably never know
for sure because
as an instrument maker Fahrenheit
was very secretive about his methods.
But I think the data strongly
suggest that this was the case.
So, what exactly did zero represent on
the scales of Fahrenheit, and Rømer?
By many accounts, it's the temperature of
salt ice and water mixture.
The only problem is there are different
descriptions of these mixtures
And none of them actually produces
the temperature they're supposed to.
More likely, I think they picked the
coldest temperature in winter
set that as zero
and later used ice and brine to
calibrate new thermometers.
In his day, the Fahrenheit thermometer
was the best you could get.
But now his scale is only
used regularly in the Cayman Islands,
Bahamas, Belize— oh, and
the United States of America.
So maybe it's time we all
adopted the global scale of temperature:
Celsius, which by the way,
wasn't invented by Celsius at all.
Hey! So that was something
a little bit different.
This video was animated by Marcello Ascani.
I've got a link to his channel in
the description.
You know, I became really fascinated
with temperature scale
after I saw the original
Celsius thermometer.
You can see that video here.
Now, this video was supported in part by
viewers like you on Patreon,
and by audible.com,
a leading provider of audiobooks
with hundreds of thousands of titles in
all areas of literature,
including fiction nonfiction
and periodicals.
And for viewers of this channel,
Audible offers a free 30-day trial
where you can download
any book of your choosing.
Just go to audible.com/veritasium.
And I have a book that
I would recommend to you.
It is called The Structure of Scientific Revolutions
by Thomas S. Kuhn.
This is a classic in the history and
philosophy of science.
And it'll make you see science
in a different way
because it shows us that
science is not just one process
but there are actually
revolutions that take place
when big discoveries are made.
And that really changed
my thinking about science
when I first read this book
ten years ago.
So you can check it out by going to
audible.com/veritasium
downloaded for free and
try out the Audible service.
I want to thank Audible for supporting
me and I want to thank you for watching.